welcome to gamma unfiltered hosted by me
Josh Smith where we meet some of the
most inspiring cyber teas every
fortnight and we get to the heart of the
issues that mean the most to them and
today we are joined by one of the
Queen's of Little Mix it's Jessie now
[Applause]
[Music]
Dave how are you I'm good but I mean
I've been on a very emotional journey
today because I've watched your
documentary which we're here for my
which is gonna be on BBC and you talk
about very movingly in fact about the
trolling you've been through your mental
health struggles and how you've
amazingly come out the other side now
for people who might not seen the
documentary yet just talk me through
what kind of journey you've been on
personally with online trolls well I
guess I just went from someone who
really wanted to perform from a really
young age that was all I knew to then go
in on X Factor which what I thought was
going to be the most incredible
experience ever to then it becoming the
worst experience of my life and it was
mainly due to social media and how much
it affected me so when it just like they
were like you know here's your mobile
phone this is what you're going to have
this you need to have Twitter because
you need to start engaging with fans you
need to start like connecting with them
they need to start knowing who Little
Mix are as I go this is cool but then
was just not the experience I expected
it to be it was just endless amounts of
comments of what people thought of me
and my appearance and I just dunno how
to deal with it what kind of comments
were the ones that were the biggest
trigger for you Joe what people comment
in on my face I think I got used to
people calling me fat because I was just
saying okay whatever I've seen it so
much and then people started going in on
like what my face it like when people
would like you know make memes and then
people would chop my head off in group
photos and replace it with a monster or
replace it with ET or a sloth and like
and I became like a bit of a like a joke
to everyone and it really really knocked
my confidence
I just never experienced anything like
it in my life and I thought I would be
able to deal with it and I couldn't
when people knew it affected me they
went in more and I found that that
baffled me a lot like you could like
they everyone could see how much it was
affecting me but yet people seem to want
to like do it even more
do you think it was it was easier for
you to deal with it because you had the
girls beside you as well I made it worse
because I was being compared to three
other girls
I honestly think if I had him in a solo
artist it wouldn't have been as bad I
don't know I'm just guessing I think
because I was with three other girls I
was being compared to them it made
people have more of an opinion so book
if I'd have been on my own if there's no
one to compare me to do not I mean I
don't know but I found it worse because
I think as well I've interviewed Leanne
about a similar thing that she went
through so she was searching out the
online hey did you guys have a discuss
it no I knew it effectively and now
she's better deal with it than me yeah
how did it affect your own personal
relationship with your body image and
beauty I never had an issue with my way
or the way I looked before X Factor
before social media and then as soon as
I got it I slowly mentally started to
believe everything that people were
saying about me it just consumed my
whole life every single part of me
relationships work friendships
everything eating like it just it
consumed me because you say very
powerfully in a documentary that you
started not telling up to work at some
points as well so when you were at home
and you're on your own and you knew that
your band mates were out there because I
think you're in like career at one point
when they're eating go what were you
doing and what were you thinking the way
I used to see it was if I'm not seen
with them I won't get pictured so there
won't be an article for people to then
come in and troll me on so I was like if
I'm not seen with them as much people
won't have an opinion but instead it
caused more of an opinion because then
there was a cause where's Jessie was she
not with the girls what was the turning
point when you when you thought you
could come back out the house again well
when I got rid of Twitter I was addicted
to social media my daily routine was
waking up six up in the morning and
typing the worse things I could about
myself on Twitter because in my brain I
thought right this is
I'm gonna deal with it if I can keep if
I keep reading these my brain will
eventually get so used to seeing them
they ain't gonna affect me anymore
because my brain will just see it and go
I've seen that already and it won't hurt
as much you didn't help at all it just
made me more and more depressed made me
a completely different person and I
eventually started speaking to a
therapist I think it's amazing you can
sit here and say that you went to
therapists and you encourage others to
do similar thing I think people quite
embarrassed almost to say that they'll
go see a therapist and it's like I don't
know something you should be ashamed of
but it isn't everyone's got problems
since making this documentary it's
helped me so much talking about it
because I couldn't before I couldn't
talk about it because it made me too
upset I think it may upset because I
wasn't talking about it and it was like
this heavy weight I was just carrying
around with me for so many years and
since I've like been openly speaking
about it I now do an interview and I
don't bloody cry what did you learn
about yourself through going to therapy
what's the biggest lesson you learn from
that I've really learned that like as
long as I'm happy within myself and like
mentally I'm happy up here it doesn't
matter what other people think
everyone's always gonna have opinion you
can't stop that as long as I feel good
in myself and I'm happy then that's all
that matters it's amazing to be able to
sit here and say that you've been on
that journey and now you're coming out
the other side sounds really sad but I
never thought I could feel happy again
ever now I'm sitting here not openly
talking about here and I never thought
I'd be sitting here making this
documentary doing this interview feeling
confident feeling empowered feeling back
to how I used to feel feeling happy
again and that is why when it's make
it's not crunchy because there's so many
people that go through life thinking
that's it that's how they're gonna feel
forever and there isn't and I think
that's why so many people you know
commit suicide because they don't see a
light at the end of the tunnel I just
want people to know that if you just
stick through it and you talk to people
it gets better
what's been the hardest thing for you to
film in this documentary or discuss me
in Sean's mum and dad an important that
go who took her own life the fact that
her mum and dad like she hasn't it's not
even been a year since she passed away
it could not openly sit there and be
that brave enough to like sit there and
tell me
her story they must be so mentally
strong to be able to do that and I just
thought it was incredible that they're
that they want to share that story
because they want to help other people
that for me like that was horrible how
did that change you and your perception
I mean it's just an eye-opener for me
that like like seeing the effects what
it does to like the people you obviously
leave behind it's another reason why I
wanted to do this because so many people
like go online and think oh whether
they're like having a laugh with their
mates and there's someone's like the
butt of the joke or whether they just
saluting that person is not going to see
it you don't know that and that person
can see there and that one comment can
completely change their mindset and how
they feel about themselves and I just
think people need to know the effects
that it has on people it's kind of sad
really because you must feel crap about
yourself to want to make someone feel
that low and I think that is why trolls
do it because they are sad within
themselves I don't feel good about
themselves and so by doing that it makes
them feel better one of the things that
really stuck with me from watching this
was when your mum said that she'd want
to just have the old you back do you
ever think or feel that you wish you
could take away the fame and never have
had to deal with the emotions you've
been through
it wasn't the fine it was social media
that was that was the main thing that
affected me and then obviously being in
the public art couldn't get away from it
I couldn't hide I couldn't just take
time off and be sad I just have to roll
with it and get on with it and that was
what I really struggled with not
pretending to be happy I think as well
you guys have some of the most
empowering songs out there yeah like I'm
always fist-pumping to them and I'm like
yes I'm really more empower from
listening to this but when you're on
stage and you're going for these
emotions internally
what are you telling yourself to get
yourself out on that stage I didn't want
to be on stage and eventually my love
performing and I just ended up hating it
and it stopped me from wanting to go on
stage and perform but things that got me
through it were like fans seeing their
support and how much like our music
affected them why when you have so many
positive comments of people being like
you're amazing you're incredible you
inspire me every day why do you think
you gave more weight
negative because it was everywhere it
was in magazines it was exploited on X
Factor
it was our couldn't get away from it
they probably wore loads of positives
didn't let myself see it because all I
saw was the bad ones and once you see
one bad comment you then see like a
million and then that that's all that
stays with you you never think about
positives because they're bad outweigh
the good what's the most extreme thing
you've done in order to try and conform
to something you thought you should be
that I so desperately wanted a
validation from other people I just want
it to be Jesse I didn't want to be just
see the fat one just wanted people to
see me as normal I just would yeah i
starved myself I just I just like
punished myself really and if I did II
hated myself I punished myself and I
made sure that I didn't eat for like
four days
it was horrible it's just a vicious
circle so one of the things that we were
just talking about was the crying and
how you actually places about this quite
recently saying sometimes out of nowhere
I'll get these random waves of sadness I
don't know why I laugh and there's a
natural emotion so why do we stop
ourselves from crying if I feel sad I
now let it out how game-changing has
that been for you I think that's why I
fell into such a deep depression because
I didn't allow myself to be sad I didn't
I just had to be happy all the time and
now many times I've got to be sad as
when I went home went sleep not cry
myself to sleep and then I got up the
next morning I was oh shoot have to
pretend to feel fabulous and happy and I
wasn't when I feel sad I'm just sad now
I'll let myself be sad and I'm over it
because I've let it out I haven't tried
to keep it in if you feel sad be bloody
sad it's okay embrace it
yeah because you'll start here right now
you're in love for yourself more than
ever before
absolutely and how amazing is it to sit
here and be able to say that this is the
most I've ever loved myself but I never
thought that would happen and I think
there's so many girls that probably feel
that way now and think they're never
going to feel good about themselves but
you can and you will and it's all about
talking and letting people know how you
feel and you will get through and you
will overcome it and you should never
forget that you're an absolute babe I
mean Xzibit
Hey right here don't forget it
thanks so much baby man amazing you're a
pig I mean it you should be so proud of
yourself
make sure you subscribe to the glamour
UK channels now see more empowering
content with such people such as Jessie
and make sure you come back in two weeks
for the next episode of glamour
unfiltered with me Josh Smith
[Music]